talking to like you know student you
know 20 something years old right what
are practical steps every person can
take to sort of like make a difference
or you know I think the problem we have
with 20 year olds is
they have been sold a bill of goods that
have to be cosmically moral
cosmically politically correct or
cosmically woke and they neglect things
that are the ingredients of a successful
and productive citizenship so every 20
year old should say to themselves am I
self-sufficient
am I polite to people do I follow the
rules of Civility I'm I'm a fair to
people do I judge people on the content
of their character and then they have to
say am I autonomous as much as a 20 year
old can be I do not want to be dependent
on people I want to be productive I want
to be the person people come to for
advice I do not want to go to other
people for subsistence